This is so cool. Bro, all you have to do All you have to do is
stop saying that it was like important to defend American interests
and just say it was like really how much you're going to kill
brown people. He's just like, "Oh my god, YOU MADE A THREAT?"
I love this now. I love George Bush now. I love neoconservatism
now.
Let's check it out. Asmongold 8 months ago This is 8 months ago
though. This is him talking about the Shah 8 months ago. Yeah,
no, this is going to be I don't blame him for being now. But
8 months ago, I don't really care that much. Yeah, I don't I
don't give a [__]
Okay. Old Asmongold takes Iran takes. We I think we covered this
earlier, but this would be a good start to just this last little
bit here if we wanted to cut this into different segments. This
is a good one. So, Asmongold in 2024 Okay.
>> This is the This is the Asmongold take in 2024 and then
2026.
We play too big of a role in other countries' military.
Like we're too interventionary. We We get too involved into other
people's
Uh it's a waste of our money. The people there probably hate
us. Like where where's really the upside here, right? Let's stay
out of it. Yeah, exactly. And I'm not saying like we should be
totally isolationist, but I think that the level that like that
we try to play nation building, especially in places like this
like, you know, like Libya for example back in the day.
what the [__] or or Iraq. No, absolutely not. Yeah,
it's too much, man. Way too much. I am actually I am so happy
this has happened. I am just dramatically tremendously happy
this has happened. I know that, you know, obviously I've talked
about it for a long time about how big of a problem Iran is and
everything. I was a big supporter of us bombing them before,
and now we're bombing them again, and this is just amazing. I
think that we we play too big of a role. Wow. Wow. Let's take
a look at this segment though. Maybe the segment overall will
not be quite so bad. So, what's happening in Iran now? Okay.
Dude, oh my Oh my god, pog.
The IDF talking to me? Oh my god.
Sorry, which one should we 2 hours, 3 hours? Let's see I'm going
to take a look and we'll just see if we can get into any substantial
conversation or if this is him going over strikes. We'll >> So,
Minister of Defense dead, head of the Supreme Military dead,
advisor to the Supreme Leader dead, Commander of the Revolutionary
Guard dead, and Chairman of SPND dead, former Chairman dead,
the head of the intel dead.
Does he know what SPND is? What is the SPND?
Uh I don't care. Dead. I don't care. Dead. That's it. >> Okay.
All right. They're all dead.
Wow. And uh senior defense officials tell Fox News United States
agrees with Israeli assessment that Iran's Supreme Leader Ayatollah
Khamenei is dead along with five or 10 other top leaders in the
Iranian government who were all I believe this is why they struck.
It wasn't even his residence. I believe this is why they struck
the the one parliamentary building, the one government building
they did, right? This is what they said. They had a meeting.
There was like a meeting that was happening above ground in Iran.
And they thought that they had an opportunity to hit. And so
they went. All meeting at Yeah, yeah. All meeting at Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Yeah, okay. Sorry, I literally didn't read the rest of
the tweet that he hadn't read yet. Yes, this is what we heard.
The first night was Israel went with this first strike because
they had intel that this was like a one-time opportunity where
they could get all these people together and they were just going
to take it.
So, wait a minute. Are you telling me that we just waited for
them all to get into one building and then we just blew up the
building? Well, that's pretty based, man. That's pretty cool.
It's just All right, fine finally. All right, all right, go.
>> Just AOE farming them. Yes, exactly.
>> So, they're just sitting around So, that means that
you know what's funny is that That means that we were tracking
every single one of them the entire time. This entire thing where
they thought that they were getting away with it and oh well,
they're not going to be able to find us and everything. We already
knew where all of them were the whole time. The moment that they
all got together, we blew them up.
Wow. Just like you said, yeah, just like I said. I said this
in
Just like you said. What did Asmongold say? Why didn't Allah
save them? Because the probably the reason why is that if there
is some afterlife, they're going to get sent to hell. These people
are horrible oppressive demons. No no no any sort of sensible
good afterlife would send these people to hell. Like they're
going and killing their own people. They're enabling and murders.
He literally he literally bought every
cattle talking point. I don't
Oh no. Oh no. Asmongold, what What are you doing? What are you
doing?
Oh, by the way, like you could be upset about this. It's like
that's not You're only being told about that cuz it will make
you be okay with this.
That's not a part of the calculation. They could have been If
these people were not If those protest crackdowns had never happened
and they had the same
right? They would still do this.
They would literally still do it. It's in their own country.
They're massively oppressive. They tore the entire country 90
80 million people into poverty and a total [__] where
the country used to be great.
Uh-huh. Yeah, they're probably not Dude, this is This is unbeatable
tech. Become the global economic superpower with the only deep
water military or sorry, deep water navy that exists and just
embargo other countries or or put trade restrictions on them
or [__] with their economy in any way.
Turn their economy into total dog [__] Watch their
their country like go into squalor and then to and then oh well
actually the regime there turned their country into a [__]
like it gives us the entire pretext to go and invade them to
go and put them to do regime change.
It's unbeatable tech man. They can do whatever they want. Getting
their 72 virgins. They're not. Why the [__] would
they? They don't deserve it. They're at
They're set Yeah, they're getting 72 demons. Well, no, they are
the 72 demons. And so anyway, that's what's happened. And here
we go. Kuwait's Ministry of Defense. And what is this here? Subjected
to another Iran Oh, another drone attack. Here we go. Wow.
Israel's been a global or sorry regional hegemon for a while
obviously in the Middle East. The issue is they don't really
have a lot of their own natural resources. So
I'm assuming it'd be good for them to have a couple of those
partners like not
working all that well. But um it's really it's coming down Turkey
is also ascendant right now. Turkey is is building I think they're
in the middle of their own military build-up. I think Turkey's
like doing pretty well as well. So I do think it's Turkey versus
Israel still. I'd say Israel's jumping out to like a a lead.
Sorry, not a hegemon of power. Sure, sure, sure. Hegemon implies
that you are the the power, the only power that matters. They're
in a they're in a power struggle with Turkey right now.
Uh-huh. Okay.
Do you have any other analysis from this guy or direct fanboys?
>> yep, that's about right. And so most humans are righted
at least. Yes, most humans function this way. Iranian one-way
attack drone. Oh, here we go. In the direct hit earlier on the
US's Navy's Fifth Fleet Headquarters. Uh-oh.
Is this the crazy one? >> There it is. Oh, what's this?
WOW, GOOD
>> JOB GUYS. Good job. And like there it is. And uh getting
72 Redditors. Yeah, 72 hogs, exactly. Yeah, wow, they blew up
one boat. Yeah, not so good. Rockets in Tel Aviv. Well, I haven't
seen that at all yet. And uh pack watch. And then I'm like
is Bibi
Okay, I I did find this I am I'm a going my own way, okay? I
did find this kind of funny. >> got blown up by nuclear
[__] Well, I'm going to go look on this
And then he blows up all my nuclear [__] I'm like
call my generals.
And they tell me they're all dead, sir. And I'm [clears throat]
like assemble the army. And they're like they're dead, too, sir.
So, then I'm like
launch the freaking missiles.
>> And they're like
they're gone, sir.
So, I'm like what the [__]
>> And then I'm like
Okay, I didn't laugh this hard at it. It's not that kind of funny.
It's like you know, slightly increased air flow through your
nostrils funny. All right. Oh, no. >> Fire the missiles.
>> slapping funny, man. These are really good. Haters will
say it's AI. Yeah, there it is. And this is his compound, right?
That that's where he was living. And uh now it's um you know,
there it is. Close to the base, the US Navy's fleet. Footage
of Iran's supreme leader's corpses Bro, I it's pretty fun funny,
actually. I mean, only if you have some sort of ideological like
like for Ayatollah Khamenei. And I don't, so. >> been shown
to Prime Minister Netanyahu.
Oh, man. Well, there it is, guys. I can I can laugh at things
that are very dark humor, okay? >> And uh I have several
off-ramps I can go. What What is What does Trump say? President
Trump told Axios in an interview on Saturday that he has several
off-ramps for for President Trump operation epic fury against
Iran.
I can go long and take over the whole thing or end it in two
or three days and tell the Iranians, "See you again in a few
years if you start rebuilding your nuclear and missile I could
tell see you
Dude. Dude. All right. Well, um Trump said in a 5-minute phone
interview, "In any case, it will take them several years to recover
from this attack." Yep, well, there it is. Explosion in Tel Aviv
now. Well, let me see this. Is this it here? I think it could
be it. Let's Uh you and you and I see just um I just you people
like try to intellectualize things that are just funny. It's
just be funny, man. Just be like a goofy thing that's stupid.
It could be funny because it's
I don't know. This is like a common leftist issue. People are
like, "Uh it's not true. Therefore, it's not funny."
I don't know if you know this, but uh lies can be funny.
They But they can. Let's find out. Propaganda can be funny. Propaganda
against something you like can be funny. It was just a few moments
ago Literally, it's true though. No, I do believe there's a substantial
Iranian army, like an IRGC army, still present in that country
that is going to be totally ready to enforce the I the I mean
the the clerics' will the the Iranian regime's will, right? It's
not necessarily true. >> seeing and hearing some of those
interceptions on the shots. So, what we're going to do is try
to keep this up on the screen for you as well as we're diving
into this new information. But, I do want to reset for folks
who are at home who have been watching with us. Maybe you haven't
been watching in the entire time as we've been getting these
minute-by-minute updates, but just joining us here on Live Now
from Fox. It has been reported by the Associated Press and Fox
News both saying that the Iran's supreme leader, Khomeini, is
now dead. And so, this comes after those strikes initially happened
in the overnight hours that were brought on by President Trump
in a joint operation with Israel. I do want to put this up on
the screen. And about the last 30 minutes or so, we saw this
come down from the White House on their X account
Hold on. Let me see if we got Does he watch like the Trump statement
or
I I got to see if he watches the Trump statement or something.
Who's this guy? That's I'm not in a position to confirm.
You don't have space. Yeah, how do you feel about that? >> It's
been closed and the country is under a near total internet blackout.
The attacks have reportedly caused significant civilian casual
Sneako did a little prayer when he found out Khamenei died, lol.
Sneako's very Sneako's a very funny guy,
Hold on. What did What did Sneako do
So, Sneako is a Shia Muslim? Um no, but I don't think you have
to necessarily like you could be some kind of Muslim
be in support of like Iran against Israel without being a Shia
Muslim. Like this is maybe the one line of This is maybe the
one line in the past
What would you say? Like this might be their one agreement is
the who death to the Israel death to Israel death to the United
States could be the only thing they agree on. But yes, he is
a grifting Muslim, so this is true, unfortunately. killed at
least 85 people and injured many more at the girls' school in
Minab, Hormozgan province. Yep. And the school in Tehran was
also reportedly hit. >> see I don't see anything else
for this, so I'm assuming his Trump reaction is in here somewhere.
Oh, okay. We We do have to watch this. I just want to see his
reaction to the Trump speech. Up two. And yeah. And so keep that
in mind every single time you see these people, oh this is them
burning an American flag. Oh, this is another time that they're
doing this. Oh jeez. Yep. Oh, there's another one. How happy
the people of Iran are right now?
The song that says we need to let Iran have nukes and we'll have
peace. Well, how about we just keep the people that want to nuke
us and then it's not a Why Why would we ever Why would Oh, he
totally believes they are going >> would we ever want to
give another country a weapon of mass destruction? It's stupid.
Like the first thing that you should do is like, bro, like what
do you mean? Just go kill them. That would be to give to give
Iran if if if you just as the United States were like, here's
the technology to fire a nuclear weapon from some ground-based
missile silo.
Here's Here's a nuclear weapon, here's the technology to fire
it. That would be >> if they're saying that they're trying
to kill you, then do it then believe them. Be like, oh really?
Damn, all right, we'll see.
We don't spend a trillion
Um I wouldn't try to make this argument that it's about cruel
being cruel or dumb. It's just not in America's interest to go
after Iran like this at
This is not.
dollars on the military for nothing, right guys?
Blow them the [__] up.
Just for shits and giggles, absolutely. And so no, I'm so happy
about this. Fox News Fox News confirmed Ali is dead. I mean maybe,
but yeah, no I can see confirmed terrified this all is now joining
us. You're going to continue to give you these updates and some
of the fallout that has been happening in the aftermath. This
just in from the Associated Press talking about what's happening
regionally there. >> that hundreds of people are now demonstrating
in Baghdad in support of Iran against those attacks that were
Oh, you said 104
10415, but 10415 didn't have it. Surely. He's playing through
it. Commanders dead. That's right. He was about to do it again.
They were about to do it again.
We'll watch it right now. So, Trump actually came out and he
made this statement about it yesterday. Here we go. Let's watch
it. Get to it. It's time. It is time. A short time ago
Turn up the audio. >> States military began
major A short time ago
the United States military began
major combat operations
in Iran.
Our objective is to defend the American people by eliminating
imminent threats from the Iranian regime, a vicious group of
very hard
terrible people.
Its menacing activities directly endanger the United States,
our troops, our bases overseas,
and our allies throughout the world. >> everybody up. Mhm.
For 47 years, the Iranian regime has chanted death to America
and waged
an unending campaign of bloodshed and mass murder.
Do we need to count the murders between these two regimes or
What do you guys think? You want to count Should we count the
murders between these two regimes? How do you think the Iranian
regime [__] So, sounding like a lefty again. targeting
the United States, our troops, and the innocent people in many,
many
Among the regime's very first acts was to back a violent takeover
of the US Embassy in Tehran, Shouldn't have done >> holding
dozens of American hostages for
days. Big miss should not have done that. Dude, is he
I swear to God, it like sounds like he's drinking during this.
Is he
Is he Is he throw a little vodka in that Dr. Pepper when he brings
it home? >> Shouldn't have done that. >> holding
dozens of American hostages for 444
days. No, you shouldn't have done that. Big miss not have done
that. You should not have done that.
In 1983, Iran's proxies carried out the Marine Barracks No, he's
not drunk. He's not the >> bombing in Beirut that Hezbollah
Hezbollah. This is the thing is that don't ever whenever somebody
says Iran never did anything Iran never killed American soldiers,
they absolutely did. They absolutely did. They they pay other
people to do it. They fund terrorist organizations that go out
and then they blow people up that are Americans. They don't do
it directly, but they pay the people to do it which
the Houthis What are the What's the Houthi count of Americans?
Hold on, let me see. Let me see. I won't do Hezbollah cuz Hezbollah
is going to have a lot. Hezbollah because of the What is it?
The
Is it the Beirut Embassy?
Is it some Beirut base or embassy that that Hezbollah blew up
that killed a bunch of Americans?
But if you go to like Perplexity,
did any of these other groups even kill Americans?
Which means that they're doing it. For 241 American military
personnel
In 2000, they knew and were probably involved with the attack
on the USS Cole. Many died.
Iranian forces then maimed hundreds of American service members
in Iraq. The regime's proxies have continued to launch countless
attacks against American forces stationed in the Middle East
in recent >> Possible deniability?
We're we're in an age of plausible
Hello. Spruce Willis, thank you for the gifted sub. I think so
it's possible that one of these ships they hit in the Red Sea
had an American sailor on it that got killed from one of the
hits.
So that is that is it seems to be the case that that might be
the one victim >> Plausible deniability doesn't work whenever
you have a big dick in charge.
It doesn't. They say, "Oh, you said you didn't do it? All right,
we're going to kill you anyway.
And then we'll see if it stops. Hopefully it'll stop, but if
it doesn't we'll kill somebody else. That's the way you deal
with them. It's that simple.
years, as well as US naval and commercial vessels in international
shipping lanes. I did. It's been mass terror, and we're not going
to put >> It's not I don't even think it's like I'm not
going to argue it's It's just a stupid thing to say or stupid
thing to do. Oh, we'll kill you and then if if it doesn't stop
we'll kill somebody else. It's like, bro, that's not One, that's
not your values. It's not like the values of your country. Two,
it's not like good values to maintain, you know, goodwill in
the world. If you don't want terrorist attacks to happen to Americans
overseas, then probably don't just start doing that, right? >> put
up with it any longer. >> It's over. From Lebanon to Yemen
and Syria to Iraq, I don't I don't care about the attitude. I
understand some people get mad when this guy's like, well, no,
these people will die. It's like I kind of get it. I do kind
of get
Like I He's not totally wrong. He's trying to say this is the
way the world works, right? He's trying to say this is the descriptive
reality of the world. If you're the biggest You got the most
weapons in the room, you get to decide how this works, right?
He's like he's doing that. Although he's totally reveling in
it, too. So, I'm not going to freak out on it freak out on him
for that reason. It's just like it's not a good calculation.
It's not the best move for the American people. It's not the
best move for
And because you're so intellectually lazy, you're just advocating
for a
That's the problem. The regime has armed, trained, and funded
terrorist militias that have soaked the earth with blood and
guts. >> Shouldn't have done it.
I mean, the thing is they can't even take care of their own people.
Like, what are you doing sending weapons and bombs and money
over to terrorists?
That was stupid. What was this here? Hezbollah knocked down US
ships cuz US is helping Israel invade Lebanon? It's a bit of
a justified situation.
No, it's not. You see, this is the way it works. Are Are attacking
our ships? If the answer is yes, then they die.
That's it.
It doesn't matter what they're just
I think that's fine. I've no concern about that.
They're attacking us, then we can attack them back. Yeah, sure.
Even if you even if you're doing something like to force the
attack or if they're helping an ally or something. Yeah, you
could you could justify that, sure. >> Yes, because they
don't matter. Don't care about that. >> want to do something,
we do it. If they try to stop us, then they die.
I I I don't I I don't know what what
As As Asmongold like in his mind wants nothing more than to be
like an African warlord, okay? Where it is just like I'm going
to [__] you, and if you fight back, I'm going to
cut your hand off. And if you keep fighting back, I'm going to
cut the other hand off. And it's like, okay, Asmongold, you're
Yeah, that's like literally I What do you want, man? I don't
know. You're You're out of your mind right now, the things you're
saying, okay?
Like it's just it's gross. It's just weird. Like Like this is
stepping over the line. You are You are just advocating for stuff
that like you don't want the world to work this way. You could
say it works that way, but then you have to understand that the
African warlord, everybody's got a gun on like pointed at them.
And then when bad things happen, you can't go, oh, [__]
you. You have to say, well, now I'm going to come hurt you for
doing that. Cuz that's the way you've made the world work. It's
not It's not right or wrong. In that world, attacking the US
is always okay. Any attack against the US is justified in the
world you just described. Is that the world you want to live
in?
It's not the world I'd want to live in personally. But hey, if
that's the world you want to live in, what are you
This isn't a Reddit. This is not a Reddit comment section.
That's not the way it works.
What What are you You You think that like that like it's about
an argument? No, it's not about an argument. We do whatever the
hell we want.
And it was Iran's proxy, Hamas >> Shouldn't have done it.
>> that launched the monstrous October 7th attacks on Israel
slaughtering more than 1,000 innocent people including 46 Americans
while taking 12 of our citizens hostage. It was brutal. Something
like the world has never seen before.
Iran is the world's number
We've never seen anything like October 7th before.
I'm going to go ahead and say like
Okay, maybe in the in the capturing of civilians. Maybe you could
make that argument um and not be like a total I still think it's
obviously wrong, right? Any of the World Wars would obviously
Trump this. But at least maybe in the model but I I'm going to
immediately go to 9/11 for the overall death and destruction.
Yo, yo 9/11, yo Trump, you really saying October 7th is worse
than 9/11?
or I guess I guess so. I guess October 7th is worth worse than
9/11 to you. You really have to you have to get into the mindset
to understand this, right? The America First guy is saying the
worst terror attack we've ever seen is October 7th. Not 9/11.
It's October 7th.
The leader of America
has said the worst terror attack something like we've never seen
before is October 7th. It's not 9/11.
Now, maybe you could argue the the and stuff the the capture
and stuff makes it
I don't think so. I just think Trump is, you know, he's saying
what he's saying what the teleprompter says. Hey, Bibi, listen,
MBS wrote me a check to get this done. I'm going to read whatever
the teleprompter says as Cenk Uygur once said, okay, I think
in 2016. Just let me read what's in the teleprompter. Stop asking
me to do stuff. Just let me I'm going to read the teleprompter.
Just let me read the teleprompter, okay?
That's what it is here, okay? >> one state sponsor of terror
and just recently tens of thousands of its own citizens on the
street as they protested. This is one of the things it's actually
shocking and appalling to me that almost none of these like virtue
signal or people in the West never
Yeah, but hold on. He's the president of the United States. So,
on the population percentage, the population the percentage of
the population that he cares about of both countries is should
be about 0% for Israel and about 100% for Americans. So, there's
a little modulating factor here that you're the leader of a country
and it had the worst terror attack against it in its history
in a city you lived in, right? You should think before you say
things is my >> Or taught or at least on English-speaking
social media, right? Almost never talked about this. Like all
these people that were crying bloody murder whenever Hamas terrorists
were getting blown up weren't talking at all about the Iranian
regime murdering their own citizens.
They weren't talking about it at all.
I wonder why.
It is always >> actually care. I've tried to say that.
People didn't want to listen. Now they're starting to realize.
It's been the policy of the United States in particular my administration
that this terrorist regime can never have a nuclear weapon. That's
right. I'll say it again. They can
Okay. So, before these strikes took place you destroyed their
nuclear capability completely. >> Never have a nuclear
weapon. That's right. That is why in operation midnight hammer
last June we obliterated the regime's nuclear program at Fordow,
Natanz, and Isfahan. Yep. After that attack we warned them next
I actually you would have to say that. Hold on. You would have
to Aspen Institute would have to bite that bullet. Like as far
as those protesters go, they were protesting. They were making
a big ruckus outside and all the IRGC guys had the guns. So,
like rip bozo on those protesters, right? It's pretty dumb. Shouldn't
have done that. It was pretty dumb. Here's how it works. They
got the big dick in the room. They [__] who they
want. So, it was pretty dumb of you guys to protest. You wanted
to not wear your hijab? Well, you're going to get [__]
killed now. Shouldn't have done that. Shouldn't have done that,
stupid [__] You shouldn't have done that. The rules
here say you have to cover your head. You want to have your head
free and open in the air? Then you're going to get You may not
like it, but that's how it is. You might not like it, but that's
how it is, guys. ever to resume their >> app take. I just
dropped an absolute fire classic app take right there, okay?
malicious pursuit of nuclear weapons. That's one of your pro-war.
Yeah, I absolutely think we should shut down Iran. And if we
have to use the military to do that, we do it. I think that they
are an existential threat, and they they want to destroy
And so, if they say that I I think I mean, honestly, like, do
I want to send a bunch of troops over there? Why the [__]
do I need to do that? Like, we have How How many bombs do we
have? Just bomb them. If they do anything annoying, then just
bomb them. If they do it again, bomb them again.
Yeah, what do you mean? Oh, you're talking about a war. You think
about a war. Like, what It's not a war. And we sought repeatedly
to make a deal. >> No way. Oh, I love that he got that
in before Trump said the thing. Oh, thank god. We tried.
They wanted to do it. They didn't want to do it. They didn't
It's not a war, guys. Don't call it a war. It's not a >> And
they wanted to do it. They didn't want to do it. They didn't
know what was happening. They just wanted to practice evil. That's
right. >> But Iran refused, just as it has for decades
and decades.
They rejected every opportunity to renounce their nuclear ambitions.
Mhm. And we can't take it anymore.
We can't take it anymore, guys.
We're tired of this back and forth It's
They attempted to rebuild their nuclear program and to continue
developing long-range missiles that can now threaten our very
good friends and allies in Europe, our troops stationed overseas,
and could soon reach the American homeland.
How do you make this argument when they can't even strike Israel
without getting their weapons intercepted?
Like Like they barely barely barely have the capacity to overwhelm
the interceptors of Israel. How in the [__] are they
hitting the USA?
Can somebody explain that to me? They get totally They get essentially
completely parried
in all of those in all of the previous attacks. There's like
what? Four hits, five hits, six hits. And that's like them doing
the biggest barrage they could possibly do. Okay? Now, that's
all bad. I don't like Israel getting struck by weapons. I'm not
going to I'm not going to say that that's good. But what I'm
saying is if they can barely scratch
how in the world are they hitting the United States? >> land.
Yep. Just imagine how emboldened this regime would be if they
ever had and actually were armed with nuclear weapons as a means
to deliver their >> Well, think about North Korea, right?
If North Korea didn't have nuclear weapons, we would have just
gone on there gone in there and gotten rid of them, probably.
Actually, there's a very long period of time where they didn't
have nuclear weapons and you didn't do that. That's literally
not That That was not the deterrent forever and ever on why people
didn't go into North Korea. There's a very long period of time.
Did Kim Jong Kim Jong Il did not get nuclear weapons, right?
That has to be under Kim Jong Un. I I understand there's like
a suspicion they had weapons and they always did missile tests.
But I don't It wasn't under Kim Jong Il that they got nuclear
weapons, was it? I mean, there's a chance it might not have happened
cuz they're next to China and South Korea. There's a chance that
might not happen. But the amount of deterrents that it has is
almost none. So,
you never want to have an opponent that has nuclear weapons.
Well, everybody Sorry. I was going to say this actually even
less. I was going to say it.
Like I had always thought that the whole thing Okay. Maybe I
thought this as a kid cuz I saw Team America World Police. I
thought they didn't have nuclear weapons. I thought that was
the whole punchline was like they were consistently being policed
and they didn't have them. Why would you want to have an opponent
that has nuclear weapons? You insane? Of course not.
Never let that happen.
For these reasons, the United States military is undertaking
a massive and ongoing operation
to prevent the People are saying they have them. I honestly,
maybe I'll look it up later, but it doesn't seem super consequential.
Like it's
people don't want to accept this, but probably I'm sure nuclear
deterrence works to some extent, okay? It It I mean it obviously
works to some extent. But like I'm sitting here and I'm thinking
like
who's the bigger threat to like a surrounding to a neighboring
state? Is Is North Korea a bigger threat to South Korea? Well,
maybe North Korea is a big threat to South Korea cuz of the literal
like the insanely close proximity. Like you could almost do like
a nuclear
bomber at that point. Not literally, but kind of as a joke. So,
maybe it's like a big deal to South Korea, but it's like Iran
has far more capacity to wage destruction to like destroy their
enemies, right? Than North Korea ever would have.
So, I don't know I don't know what the capacity like North Korea
has. Yeah, maybe a dirty bomb or something. Sure, sure, sure.
Maybe a dirty bomb or something would be the scariest thing for
North Korea if they have like fissile material. >> wicked,
radical dictatorship
from threatening American our core national security and
I was just saying the deterrent effect of the nukes in North
Korea, right? The deterrent effect of those nukes is probably
about the same as the deterrent effect of attacking Iran, right?
With the amount of destruction they could wage.
Like I would say I'm factoring in the fact that I don't think
North Korea has like an effective ICBM.
I think they basically don't have very long range. Anyway, he
could go Oh, yeah, he could go for the three He could go for
the big
If Trump gets rid of Cuba, Iran, and Venezuela
all in This was This was basically what I thought I thought it
was basically like the USSR into China was like the reason nobody
attacked North Korea. Like 1 year?
>> God damn.
Like I thought North Korea was basically considered a part of
China. China's sphere of influence. >> Yeah, that that
would be insane.
We are going to destroy their missiles and raise their missile
industry to the ground. It will be totally again obliterated.
We're going to annihilate their navy. We're going to ensure that
the region's terrorist proxies can no longer destabilize the
region or the world and attack our forces and no longer use their
IEDs or roadside bombs as they are sometimes called to so gravely
wound and thousands and thousands of people including many Americans.
And we will ensure that Iran does not obtain a new I'm also really
glad because this is a symbolic victory as well. This is another
victory against the reductive brain-dead
trash
like
third-worldist mentality.
It is one more country that is in the
for doing this.
For doing what? I Does he think uh What does he think Iran's
doing? I guess maybe the state sponsorship of terrorism? Maybe
that's unique for them? Does Do you think Asmongold, if he's
concerned about people who crack down on dissidents, who sponsor
state terrorism against the United States and Israel, wait until
this hears about Saudi Arabia. Hey Asmongold, you ever heard
of a little event called 9/11? You ever wonder where the money
for that came from? Hey,
you ever hear about 9/11?
That's what happened. This is one more L for those people.
I'm going to get rid of all of them.
nuclear weapon. It's a very simple
>> never have a nuclear weapon. Cuba next. >> This
regime will soon learn that no one
You know
I don't know if Saudi has I don't think Saudi has nuclear deterrence.
But you know MBS be working on nuclear deterrence somewhere.
That they're going to have a way more complex way of hiding this.
They're You know MBS like in the back of his head is like, I
need new I need nukes super bad. I'm out of here in like 30 years,
40 years tops if I don't got nukes. >> the strength and
might of the United States armed forces.
I built and rebuilt our military in my first administration.
And there is no military on earth even close to its power, strength,
or sophistication.
My administration has taken every possible step to minimize the
risk to US personnel in the region. Even so, and I do not make
this statement lightly,
the Iranian regime seeks to
The lives of courageous American heroes may be lost and we may
have casualties.
That often happens in war. Yep. >> But we're doing this
not for now. We're doing this for the future and it is a noble
mission.
We pray for every service member as they selflessly risk their
lives to ensure that Americans and our children will never be
threatened by a nuclear armed
We ask God to protect all of our heroes in harm's way. And we
trust that with his help the men and women of the armed forces
will prevail.
We have the greatest in the world and they will prevail. >> Sure
seems that way. To the members of the Islamic Revolutionary Guard,
the armed forces, Somebody says, "Do you think that the uh the
Chinese and the Russian armies are getting close to our military
power?" I think that anybody that thought that probably doesn't
think that anymore.
Like I you know, like be before the Ukraine war, you could probably
assume a lot of people thought, "Oh, Russia was really dangerous,
right?"
Ah, jeez. Like, yeah, I I don't know about that, guys. And all
of the police,
Where'd that word come from? Where Sorry, where'd that word come
from? War? >> tonight that you must lay down your weapons
and have complete immunity, or in the alternative, face certain
death.
this and all of the police,
Ah, I just it's so amazing. I don't think I could I don't think
I dislike this guy enough, actually. I think I'm I'm like actually
too kind to him. I'm actually way too nice to this Asmongold
guy. I think I Asmongold is hold on. Hold on. Is this the one?
This is it, right? This is the guy?
This is literally his video, right? Right? The Griffin Gaming.
The Asmongold is this guy, but for like
Trump speeches, videos of of the US military bombing somebody,
he's doing this. This is Asmongold every single time, okay?
We have This is who he is.
But this is your fight.
This is Asmongold watching any
American military strike happen.
Donald Donald Trump speaking about going to war with another
country.
Every time, man. Every time.
Venezuelan fishing boat gets struck off the coast of the US?
Hold on. Hold on. Uh Renee good shot by a random cop in the streets.
HOLD ON. WHAT'S COMING UP NEXT? What's the next one? What's the
next one? I'm trying to think. I'm trying to think. Um oh, Maduro
captured out of Venezuela.
Coming up in 1 second.
Dude, I swear that's like Asmongold, okay? That's Asmongold
for all of these all of these things every single time. It's
awful, okay?
It's awful to watch sometimes.
I'm so You think I'm joking? You think I'm joking? >> complete
immunity or in the alternative, face certain death.
this and all of the police, I say tonight that you must lay down
your weapons and have complete immunity.
It's not even It's not even like I You think I like doing this?
You think I like doing this? >> or in the alternative,
face certain
HOHOHO. [laughter] OH MY GOD. All right. Well, um I guess that's
what happens, right?
Uh [snorts] okay.
Just let them know, right? Just let them
So, lay down your arms and you will be treated fairly with total
immunity or you will face certain death. Finally, to the great
proud people of Iran, I say
We could have done Alex Pretty. We could have done Alex Pretty.
Yeah, sure, sure, sure, sure. I Listen, the bit the bit could
go further. That was just the thing I thought of when you were
saying that. >> of your freedom is at hand. Stay sheltered.
Don't leave your home. It's very dangerous outside. Bombs will
be dropping everywhere.
When we are finished, take over your government. It will be yours
to take. Oh my god.
Hohoho. [laughter] This is this is crazy.
This will be probably your only chance for generations.
We bomb, you pillage. That's right. For many years you have asked
for Oh my god, guys. It's just like The Hunger Games, guys. It's
like The Hunger Games. They have to rise up, guys. They can rise
up. It's like The Hunger Games. >> America's help, but
you never got it.
No president
Oh my god, it's the same. was willing to do what I am willing
to do tonight. >> Yep. Now you have a president who is
giving you what you want. So let's see how you respond.
America is backing you with overwhelming strength and dev Okay.
Okay. Listen.
That's That's a crazy That's a crazy
>> sading force. Now is the time to seize control of your
destiny and to unleash the prosperous and glorious future that
is close within your reach. This is badass. This is the moment
for action. Do not let it pass. May God bless the brave men and
women of America's armed forces. May God bless the United States
of America. May God bless you all. Thank you. That was good.
God damn, bro. Like him saying like yep, lay down your weapons
or we're going to Bro, this guy go Dude, I feel like if you could
look at any example of Asmon. So we could go back to the clip,
the original clip here, or we could go to like any example of
this guy talking for the past 5 years. Trump just gave like a
quintessential George Bush speech from 2004.
And Asmongold has probably built his entire political identity
off of being opposed to that exact ideology. And now he's sitting
here, "This is so cool."
Bro, all you had to do All you had to do is stop saying that
it was like important to defend American interests and just say
it was like how much you're going to kill brown people and after
is totally on board, okay? Instantly. He's just like, "Oh my
god, YOU MADE A
"I LOVE THIS NOW. I LOVE GEORGE Bush now. I love neoconservatism
now. Oh my god, all I needed was a threat. All I needed was you
to say it's like I'm going to kill you unless you unless you
give everything up, okay?"
Awesome. Oh, and other countries'
like we're too interventionary. We We get too involved into other
people's business.
Uh it's a waste of our money. The people there probably hate
us. Uh like where where's really the upside here, right? Just
stay out of it. Yeah, exactly. I'm not saying like we should
be totally isolationist, but I think that the level that like
that we try to play nation-building, especially in places like
this, like you know, like
Okay, anyway, anyway, anyway. Okay. We watch his He's watching
the speech. He's going to watch Keir Starmer. He's going to hate
everything Keir Starmer says. Literally every single thing that
could be said here by Keir Starmer, he would absolutely hate.
He would despise
Just [snorts] be real.
This This is all he heard is all he took away from the speech.
Listen. >> was good. God damn, bro. Like him saying like,
"Yep, lay down your weapons or we're going to kill you." This
is insane, man. Like I I I I didn't even Yeah, I I I didn't even
expect to see this [__] happen. Like holy God damn,
Marco wrote it. I guess so. What are your thoughts? I mean, I
think this is great. This is amazing. It It It's incredible.
It's a It's a miracle, man. And It's a miracle, eh? It's a Very
interesting way to frame that. It's a miracle.
Who's this guy been talking I want this guy's I want this guy's
cell phone records right now. Who the [__] this guy
been talking to? Last I checked in on this guy, he's repeating
Nick Fuentes one-to-one. Now, the intervention into Iran on behalf
of Israel is a miracle, okay?
I need I need this guy's cell phone records. I need his Discord
logs. I need everything right now. Who the [__] this
guy been talking to? What's happening? >> Yeah, I'm very
happy about it. I'll tell you that. I'm extremely happy. So are
the Iranian people. They're very happy, too. So, we'll go through
some of the other comments and everything that people have been
saying, right? I'm pretty sure the Iranian people are not happy
by any measure, okay? Not that they don't I'm sure a lot of Iranians
are totally cool that the regime is getting pressured or or like
the regime leadership has been taken out. I'm sure a lot of them
hate the regime leadership. But ultimately, they're pretty [__]
up right now, okay? They don't have water. They can't feed themselves.
It's like everything's [__] up there right now, okay?
Well, actually, I don't know food's necessarily a problem. Water's
definitely a problem, though. Okay? They're not happy. Things
aren't getting better because bombs are raining down on them.
There's nobody who's sitting under under [clears throat] the
combined might of both Israel and United States intervention
and going, "This is awesome. This is way better than before.
This is awesome. I love that this is >> Right. This is
all the people, as I said, dancing in the streets, man. Dancing
in the streets, happy as hell. There it is.
Man, it's all a [__] around before
Where are they dancing in the streets, exactly? Iranians are
dancing in the
Maybe that is Tehran. Maybe. Looks kind
Looks kind of, you know, I I don't think these people would be
dancing in the middle of the street in Tehran, just saying. People
usually don't starve. Well, I'm saying I think they've had supply
issues because of the trade restrictions in their country. But
I don't know if they're having food shortages yet. They're definitely
having water shortages. It's London. The other one was London.
I don't know if this >> Or they would never even found
out, exactly. Yeah. Chuck OSINT. Oh, no, we're going to get through
it. Yeah, we are. We're going to get through everything. It's
just going to take some time, man. That's all. And then Keir
Starmer. Okay, let's listen to him. Let's compare Let's compare
the two statements. Earlier this morning, the United States and
Israel struck targets in Iran.
Iran has since launched indiscriminate
across the region.
I know the >> Does I feel like that kind of proves it was
the right call, huh? British people
and communicate How would that prove it's the right call?
across our country Oh, okay. >> will be deeply concerned
about what this means
for security and stability
and for the I I will say
I did think it was a bit weird. Like striking Okay.
To me, striking military bases of Americans makes sense, okay?
To be like You're You're sort of That has like symbolic value.
Striking the Burj Khalifa actually baffles me. To be honest with
you. Like straight up just striking the Burj Khalifa, trying
to send drones to the Burj Khalifa, that confuses the heck out
of me. I actually don't understand that at all.
Like it is bad I don't understand the calculus. I Beyond the
fact that the UAE, I'm sure they think the UAE is an American
puppet. I'm sure they think that, right?
But um I don't think that it was intentional. You don't think
drones flying at the Burj was
I feel like it had to be intentional. I >> fate of innocent
people across the
>> Which for so many of us So he's trying to condemn >> loved
ones and family members.
So whilst the situation is evolving very
I want to set out our response.
Oh my god. >> Kingdom played no role in these strikes.
Um I don't think the bridge Dude, I saw it like burning wreckage
falling off of the Burj.
I'm pretty sure it got hit. I'm pretty sure it's like undeniably
been hit.
We watched this drone fly right by it and explode. And then we
watched at least one of them get um we watched like burning wreckage
falling off of it. So, maybe maybe those clips were misidentified,
possibly. I don't think so, though. Possibly, though.
Okay. Um What was I going to I was about to do something as I
was going to talk there, and then we get the donation.
It's based on what Keir Starmer was just saying. What was he
saying? Oh, that they played no role. Right. I was going to say
it seems odd to me that there's no part of this that's like,
well, when you plant when you have like peace talks, and then
you plant future peace talks that are a week later, I think the
implication is you're not going to war in between. Now, maybe
they made it explicit that they weren't, but I feel like when
you're engaged in peace talks and you're like, well, that was
productive. We're going to come back in a week and keep talking
to you. I think like is there no part of anybody who just goes,
well, that's just that's dishonesty on a on the world stage on
the global stage. That ruins your like word. That that degrades
you as the global hegemon. When you when you go to say we're
going to engage in peace talks with you, and then in the middle
of those peace talks you start bombing
That to me degrades your integrity as a superpower.
And it's the second time your integrity has been degraded this
way by Israel leading the strikes. It's the second time you've
been made to look like complete baboons by the Israeli
It shouldn't have been The first time you maybe chalk it up to
a mistake. You just got played a second time force to continue
on Or maybe they just planned to. I don't know. But it's like
the second time this happened. I want to set out our
Oh my god. >> Kingdom played no role in these strikes.
I think he's just saying this to maintain the radical Islamic
voting base that they have in Europe. I think that's the reason
why he's saying it. Okay, I think I think Klieman might be back
tomorrow or the next day. We'll see. I think Klieman's back pretty
soon. You have to get this video to him. Somebody has to get
this specific clip to him where Asmongold's commenting on the
Keir
I need to listen.
I'm It's really lonely being the only person who's banned from
YouTube, so get this clip to Queen Man when he's streaming on
YouTube, okay? Thank you. I'll I'll have more company over here.
>> This actually probably has nothing to do at all with
like what their national interests are. This is just him playing
footsie with those people.
But we have long been clear.
>> The regime in Iran is utterly appalling.
They have murdered thousands of their own people brutally suppressed
dissent
>> and sought to destabilize the region. But But what How
do you think you How do you How do you think you solve that?
Are you going to have another talk with them? Why don't you have
another meeting with them?
Even in the United Kingdom
the Iranian regime poses a direct threat to dissidents
and to the Jewish community. >> So you're saying that like
you just didn't help because you even though you know they're
bad?
Over the last year alone
they have backed more than 20 potentially lethal attacks
on UK soil. >> So why didn't you do Why didn't you help
>> So it is clear
they must never be allowed to develop a nuclear weapon. Well,
how do you stop them from doing it? You stop them from doing
that by killing them. Bro,
Somebody needs Somebody needs to take Asmongold aside and explain
to him the concept of take yes for an answer. Hey,
this guy's entirely on your side right now. He is literally on
your side and saying you are correct. Shut the [__]
up and say thank you for agreeing with us. He's literally Keir
Starmer is saying, "Yeah, obviously like I'm I'm okay with striking
Iran in some senses. It's in some cases. We weren't behind this,
I think what Keir Starmer is trying to say is our word is still
good. We aren't totally duplicitous losers. The United Kingdom
aren't a bunch of lying scum.
But, we do think that striking Iran is not necessarily bad. We're
not lying degenerate scum like the United States and Israel,
but we do believe the Iranian regime is a real problem. That's
how you stop them. You destroy the government, you blow them
all up, you blow up all their facilities, you kill their scientists,
you kill the leaders in the military, and that's it. It's
Like how how do you think you stop it? Like you're going to have
a conversation you have Oh, let's let's do another treaty. Let's
let's let's let's write
Just for example, can can somebody get me like a count? I would
love to see the analysis of terrorism uh from Iran or its proxies
and how it mapped onto whether or not they were under the nuclear
treaty.
Like how do we how do we map that on?
treaty down so they can break it again. All right. That remains
the primary aim They didn't break the treaty. The United States
exited the treaty and then pressured other people to exit the
>> of the United Kingdom
and our allies
including the US. Uh-huh.
I condemn Iran's attacks today
on partners across the region. >> Wow, good job. >> which
are not parties to this conflict.
We extend our support >> They are. I bet Saudi Arabia and
the guys in Qatar and I bet they knew this was going to
I mean, you really think that they didn't know this was going
to happen? Like Trump didn't give them a Oh, no, no, Saudi Arabia
knew for sure. Saudi Arabia, I think I already read an article
here. Well, I did I actually didn't read it. I just took the
headline and agreed with it. I took the headline and said, yeah,
I believe this 100%. I didn't actually read it. But I I saw a
headline that was Saudi Arabia basically knew about the attacks
and PUBLICLY THEY'RE LIKE, NO, BUT PRIVATELY they're like, yes,
get those Shia Muslims.
So, Paul be like, hey man, like you know like this is where things
are going to go. Like, of course they knew this was going to
happen.
On solidarity to them,
as part of our commitments
to the security of our allies in the Middle
we have a range of defensive capabilities
in the region, Ah. >> which we recently strengthened. Oh.
Our forces are active >> They're in the group chat, yeah.
>> and British planes are in the sky today. British planes?
>> As part of coordinated regional defensive operations.
>> Wow. To protect our people,
our interests, and our allies,
as Britain has done before,
in line with international law. International law? >> We stepped
up protections for British bases and personnel
to their highest >> Has there ever been I honestly think
that maybe we should just get him before we go to Cuba.
We could just arrest him. I I feel like maybe we could just do
that. Cuz I mean, nobody likes him, right? Nobody likes him.
Why don't we just go get him?
>> Just go get him. Just go get Just go get Keir Starmer.
It's fine. It's fine. Yeah, like I'm saying that right, right?
I saw Don Double said something about my pronunciation earlier.
Is it Starmer or is it Starmer?
Where's the Oh, I I don't know why I say Starmer. Keir Starmer.
My bad. And also, I By the way, y'all can't even protect your
own women. You get You're having your women get raped like crazy
over there. You got rape gangs running around. Y'all don't even
want to talk about it. You're talking about jets in the air.
What about on the sidewalk? What about on the street?
What about on the sidewalk, bro? What about on the sidewalk?
Talk about jets in the air. What about jets on the sidewalk,
bro? You're not doing anything. level. What a joke. We are also
reaching out
>> nationals in the region Mhm. and doing everything we
can to support
Is Asim going to talk about how he right What a limp
I've been speaking with leaders today
from the E3
and across the region. Well, whenever whenever this guy if I
restore Britain ever ever like takes over they need to we need
to put him on exile. We need to find an island to put him on.
Maybe we Why don't we send him to to Epstein Island?
Actually, I think this would be a good idea. If You probably
saw that joke. I think there's a joke about exiling Trump to
Epstein Island. He probably saw the joke. Is that you take Little
Saint James Island and you make it like a exile area for every
politician
and very rich powerful person that they all have to go and be
in that island.
That they can't leave the island
It's like basically it's like a it's like an elite prison island.
Uh-oh. Wait, wait. Comment is in the chat. He's not advocating
for transfer properties. Not advocating for transfer wealth.
Do not be fooled. He did just say imprison a bunch of rich and
powerful people. Like Napoleon, exactly, right? Like Napoleon.
And then we have people guarding the island so none of them can
leave. The island's not big enough? That's not my problem. That's
their problem. [__] them. Who cares? It is vital
that we prevent further
and return to a diplomatic process.
We want to see peace and security. >> There's no diplomatic
See, the diplomatic process
is what got you to this situation.
You can't be diplomatic with people that aren't diplomatic.
This is This is just like this is the idea, bro. Like this is
the This is the Karen mind at work. Oh, hold on. Hold on. I'm
going to put this back in the chat one more time, guys. Uh we
do want Listen, if you are there, if you can if you can and you
have not done so yet, go Juicy tweet, okay? We want this. We
want this. We want people calling this guy Asmongold by tomorrow,
okay? It's very important we get this juiced because we need
people calling this guy Asmongold en masse by tomorrow, okay?
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. What to Critical critical support
of the Asmongold moniker.
>> Iran can end this now.
They should refrain from further strikes. They sure can. >> their
weapons programs.
And cease the appalling violence and >> happens if they
don't? This is the issue that this guy and like these people
don't don't have is that like you you're like this is what they
should do. They need to do this. They have to do this. Please
do this. Like why do they they don't have to listen to you? You're
nobody. Like why would they care?
Against the Iranian So, leader of the United Kingdom, he's probably
laying out his conditions for like peaceful cooperation. They're
not going to do anything. Who deserve the
>> their own future. >> No solution, just condemnation.
>> long-standing position. Another strongly worded letter.
>> This is the route to de-escalation.
And back to the negotiating table.
Negotiating [snorts]
>> negotiating table. Oh my god. Like who is this guy?
How did you how did this even happen? Oh my god, what a loser.
What a massive loser. Khamenei's house satellite photos? Uh-oh.
Dude, I Oh my god, I'm not going >> Hold on, I'm not going
to say anything.
What house? Yeah, what do you mean by that? Holy sh That looks
permanent. Yeah, I think that's I think he's dead, guys.
Discombobulated? No, I think this is the old this is the old
way, right? And wow.
Khamenei can see his home from here. I guess so. Iranian leader
confirmed dead. Oh, absolutely. And we'll look Look some of the
other comments about this, too, cuz there's been even more of
this. Oh, here we go. And so the Israel Defense Forces announced
so that bro
Okay, this is where his segment picked up. Okay, I think that's
that's enough for us today. I think that's enough. We we we went
through everything. The the good bits were earlier. The good
bits with the with the Trump reaction, okay? We got that. We're
all good with it.